أشعر بالقلق من أن النشاط الروسي
خلال الثلاثين يومًا الماضية قد تزايد بشكل واضح فيما
يتعلق
بالطائرات المقاتلة الروسية التي تضايق طائراتنا بدون طيار في
سوريا وأه لقد أجبروا على إسقاط واحدة
قبل بضعة أسابيع لقد ألحقوا الضرر بهذه الطائرة وقد
تمكنوا من القيام بذلك  العودة إلى المطار ولكن
أعتقد أن هذا أه هذا
روتين وسيستمر إذا لم
يتصاعد وأعتقد أنه يتطلب
ردًا أعني أننا نتذكر ما حدث في وقت
سابق من هذا العام على ما أعتقد في مارس عندما أجبرت
الطائرات الروسية على الابتعاد  طائرة ريبر بدون طيار
في البحر الأسود أه سببت ضررا
سقطت وأه ما لم يلفت
الانتباه بعد ذلك هو أن
البنتاغون أصدر أوامر أه
رحلات مراقبة سيئة أعتقد على بعد 50 ميلا
من المكان الذي كانوا يطيرون فيه وهو ما
أتخيله على الأرجح  يضر بقدرتنا على
إجراء المراقبة والاستطلاع
يعرف الأشياء وينظر. أعتقد أن موسكو
رأت أن هناك فائدة من القيام بذلك
إذا تراجعنا نحن وربما
يحاولون فعل الشيء نفسه هنا
ولهذا السبب مرة أخرى أعتقد أننا بحاجة إلى ذلك
التراجع عن هذا الأمر، قلت في ذلك الوقت
إنه ربما يتعين علينا وضع قبعات مقاتلة
هناك أيضًا لحماية هذه
الطائرات لإشارة إلى الروس بأننا
لن يتم الضغط علينا في سوريا
أو في أي مكان آخر ولكن من الواضح أن هذا أمر جيد.
نتيجة لهذا التصعيد